My surgeon has suggested before by double mastectomy to get clips inserted into the suspicious
lymph nodes. Then during surgery she'll make sure to remove those clips along with central
lymph nodes to send to pathology. She doesn't seem she doesn't like to rely on quick pathology
done during surgery because she has gotten bad results before.
What's you know it's always nice to do it while you have the patient open another table but
if she's experienced you know bad results because the pathology report was wrong then
you know I think that's a good note she's being safer than sorry so I think that's positive.
After we see the results and whether those lymph nodes have cancer then she do a second surgery
to remove 8 to 15 molar lymph nodes she says this is conservative and I've asked for a
microsurgery to reach hatch blood vessels lymph blood lymph vessels to decrease chances of lymphedema
doesn't sound like a good reason to play them but it sounds like she's been very thorough I'd say
it's a reason to play in yes that sounds good. Part two is if there is cancer in the lymph node she
highly recommends radiation and says cancer has a 70% chance of returning it if I don't.
I never like it when a person when a doctor throws a figure out like that because this is completely
rubber numbers here so what do you mean if it has 70% chance of returning it if you don't you
actually keep those statistics I don't think so. So I am adhering from both you and doctors
siblings that radiation is more destructive in curative. So I have never said that it's more
destructive than curative but I am not a fan of soft tissue radiation except for something like
the prostate or something like that but doing radiation post surgery they're doing kind of a blanket
big swat radiation. There's a lot of things to damage around your breasts including blood vessels
and very important or called your heart. So I'm not a big fan of doing radiation I know it is
standards of care to do low back to be plus radiation and chemotherapy if you're doing a low back to
me and then it's standards of care used to be it might be changing now used to be if you do
a mastectomy then no radiation and chemotherapy and but if you're doing a lot back to me you have to do
radiation just because that's what the pharmaceutical company put together does not mean it's right for you
so you know get you know called so for the multitude of people to make that decision.
Are there any studies I could show them? I know I cite some studies in my book I don't have the
most top I had but I don't think sighted studies to your oncologists or your surgeon are going to help
one bit but could actually hurt you because they could have some negative thoughts about you
you just got to say you know about comfortable with that or all cross-operage when I get there
and you could make a decision understand sometimes people are suggesting things
because they're trying to cover their tail so from a from a
point of view that from their point of view they're they have to make suggestions that their
clinic group is telling them to make or they could be in trouble with their clinic group they could
lose their job they could lose their insurance there's all sorts of things that they have to be
careful so even though maybe if they got cancer they want to do that so